المشاهدين الكرام في فقره وقفه مع الحدث
رمتان عويتيه التي نستعرض معها ابرز
الاسلحه النوعيه التي ستدخل المعركه في
اوكرانيا وكيف ستؤثر على النزاع مرحبا
راوتر
الجدل حول التزويد اوكرانيا بالمدرعات
الثقيله يدخل هذه الحرب منعطفا جديدا مع
اقتراب حلول عام على بدايه هذا النزاع
فنتوقف بدايه عندما تملكه روسيا من اليه
هذه الاليه التي هي مدرعه من طرازتي 90 ام
وقد اثبتت خلال الساعات الاولى والايام
الاولى من الحرب بانها لا تتوام مع الصحه
المعركه حيث اضطر عدم همم
تحول اذن هذه المدرعه وتزويدها بالطاقه
والامدادات الى همم اذا همم
عن الكثير منها في اا محيطي العاصمه اكيف
وهذا ما جعل روسيا تغير استراتيجيتها من
استراتيجيه الدكي الحصون البريه الى
استراتيجيه القصف المكثف فلنظر معا الى ما
وعدت به بريطانيا في تحول النوعي في
الاسلحه بريطانيا وعدت بتقديم هذه
المدرعات وهي من طراز 14 مدرعه من طراز
تشالنجر 2 هذه المدرعه اثبتت فعاليتها في
كل من كتب وفي العراق ايضا وتعد ايضا من
بين ابرز المدرعات المضاده
للقذفات وتملك ايضا 52 قاذفه همم اذا
يمكنها ارسال 58 قادفه وهو سلاح النوعي
لكنه ال- التقدم اذا يتيح للجيش همم
الاوكراني استراتيجيه التقدم والدك الحصون
حصون العدو بالنسبه لبولاندا وعدت بتقديم
14 مدرعه من طراز ليوبار اثنان هذه
المدرعه من صناعه اا الصناعه الالمانيه
وهي الاولى عالميا لانها تتسم بالصلابه
اولا وتتسم بالسرعه وهي كثيرا جيده بنسبه
للمسارح مسارح المعركه مثل الحال في
اوكرانيا المشكله الان بان بولندا لا
تستطيع تقديمها هذه المدرعات بدون اذن من
المانيا هذه هي العقده وبيت القصيده الان
حتى الان فرنسا المانيا بالفرنسا المانيا
والولايات المتحده قدموا مساعدات لوجستيه
تدريب واسلحه وذخيره بالاضافه الى همم
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات كل هذه الاسلحه
لديها قاسم مشترك وهو قاسم دفاعي وهو هذه
هي النقطه التي تلتزم بها هذه الدول في
دعم اوكرانيا بالنسبه اذا هنا لفرنسا كانت
طاقه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه الى اقتراح
تزويدي اذا اوكرانيا بهذه الاليه هي اليه
مدرعه سريعه وهي دفاعيه اكثر منها همم
هجوميه هي من طراز 50,000 اليه من طراز
امكس 10 اغسي بالنسبه لالمانيا ايضا همم
تطوعت او وعدت بتقديم 50 اليه مدرعه
المانيه من طراز ماردر في الولايات
المتحده ايضا وعدت بتقديم اليات مدرعه
سريعه من طراز براجيا كل هذه الاليات
تساعد في التحرك في التقدم وفي الدفاعي عن
النفس هذه هي النقطه الان مع تحول المعركه
الاخرانيه الى منعطف جديد ومع قربه هذه
المعركه من عامها الحديث هو يت- يت-
يتداول يتم تداوله الان حول ضروره دك
العدو الذي
الروسي بالنسبه لاوكرا للخروج من هذه
الحرب لان
التكافؤ على الارض معناه ربح سياسي للرئيس
بوتين وهنا ال- ال- الجدل الدائر الان في
العواصم الاوروبيه هو كالاتي هو ان تتحارب
ان تتحول هذه الحرب من حرب بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا الى حرب بين اوكرانيا وبين
اوكرانيا وروسيا ومن وراءها النيت
وبالتالي حرب مباشره هنا بين روسيا وبين
حلف شمال الاطلسي وهو السيناريو الذي ظلت
الدول الاوروبيه ودول حلف شمال الاطلسي لا
تريده لفت او تتفاداه لفتره طويله
انا مثلا
في فقره وقفه مع الحدث